All Smiles in Germany last weekend
nairishi sunak is to meet the president
of the European Commission in the UK
tomorrow as a brexit agreement over
Northern Ireland closes in
from brexit Rebel turned Minister Steve
Baker a thumbs up this afternoon are you
gonna resign over it no trouble here at
least but the government may still face
familiar rows as the cabinet begin
priming their party to expect progress
hopefully there'll be good news in a
matter of days not not weeks but if we
can get this resolved for the people of
Northern Ireland for the businesses for
the communities and frankly uh the
manifesto pledge we made really to
thoroughly properly fully get brexit
done to be a major achievement
but could there be a recognizable
roadblock Boris Johnson has already been
agitating against his successor and this
prominent brexiteer isn't sounding keen
on the reported concessions either just
putting a couple of you know
intermediate phases in but in a
situation where you still end up with
the European court of justice is
effectively sophistry I mean we're not
stupid
what we want is a situation where EU law
is expunged from Northern Ireland
Rishi sunak has squeezed more from the
EU than his predecessors but with MPS on
alert for an imminent vote there's still
a question about whether the Prime
Minister has got the politics right in
the UK when Theresa May lived here her
brexit deal fell apart because while she
was negotiating in Brussels she wasn't
squaring off the political forces back
home now Rishi sunak risks making the
same mistake with many wondering whether
he's really laid the groundwork for some
hard to swallow compromises both here
and in Belfast
while sounding positive earlier this
month a withering reception from the dup
in Northern Ireland would heighten the
chance of the prime minister's deal
falling apart and collapse the key aim
of getting the devolved institutions in
Belfast running again it is important
that he's included the unionists within
that dialogue he should have probably
have done that months and months ago so
that they felt included and of course
there are concerns about the ERG and his
own back benches but notwithstanding
that if he does get a deal then credit
to him
the border the brexiteers and the Prime
Minister it's a familiar story but one
Rishi sunak hopes will have a different
ending this time Rob pal Sky News in
Westminster